Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah Yes.
Checking it on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
How you doing man?
That's fucking Thursday goad.
One more day.
Go.
We get fucking paid today.
Friday.
He just fucking skate through that shit.
Smile and nod.
And whenever you say boss and it's a fucking weekend kid.
Um,
what's going on?
I'm taping this on a Wednesday afternoon.
Um,
so hopefully it's up nice and early few guys.
cause I'm on the road again chicka boom chicka boom,
boom,
boom.
Um,
I'm actually not doing a comedy weekend.
This is a guys trip that I was going to do.
Uh,
because uh,
my lady,
my wife,
my lovely wife,
you know,
she went somewhere with the girlfriends earlier this year,
so I said all right.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Get out there,
have a good time.
Yeah,
you get all of that cause I know.
Then I got,
I got you.
I got an a sedan,
you know,
whatever the fucking expression is and I'm just like,
I'm going to take a guys trip.
Where am I going?
None of your fucking business,
all you know,
is his great white sharks and involved.
All right.
Um,
and a lot of sunblock.
I'll tell you about it next week.
All right?
That's what they call an radio business.
That's called a teaser in the podcast business.
I don't know what it's called,
but,
um,
in the radio business,
as I learned from,
uh,
Greg Ob Hughes,
that's called a teaser.
It's a teaser.
Uh,
let's get down to what really fucking matters.
the New England
patriots,
yet
to put it out there playing tonight.
They're playing them.
Houston,
Texas down there in Houston,
Texas.
Get it near the Houston Texans from Houston,
Um,
yeah.
Voted one of the fattest cities in America and they won the crown a couple of
years.
You know what I mean?
They didn't hold onto the title.
So they were sort of like a,
a,
I dunno,
Buster Douglas.
They were like the buster Douglas of fat people,
which is what you want to be.
You don't want to like own an error being that fat.
Right?
Let's see.
Let's check our in a Houston fattest city.
Let's see where they will see where they rank.
Let's see where they rank.
Can you tell like our third string quarterback is going to be in when I'm really
just have to attack the fucking weight of the people there for years,
Houston has been hampered with the title of America's fattest city.
I stand corrected there.
The fucking,
uh,
they're,
they're the Mike Tyson.
Maybe not the Mike Tyson.
I would go more Larry Holmes of fat cities.
You know?
How long did Larry hold on for the title to the title?
Like 80 to 84 maybe.
He had a nice three four year run there,
if I remember.
But according to one report,
that accolade belongs to Houston no more.
The title of America's fattest city now belongs to Shreveport,
Bossier,
Louisiana.
A fucking city.
They're the fair,
that's like division two city as far as division one.
Wow.
That's,
that's,
you know what that does little Pale involved there.
You know what I mean?
Houston was just so sick of being called fat that they paid off the judges in
like,
you know,
if you still lose as Houston doesn't lose the fucking title to Shreveport,
Bossier City,
you did lose it to like Chicago,
Los Angeles.
See a major fucking a team that has,
uh,
a city that has a football team.
That's what I say.
You don't necessarily have to have a football team,
but you got to have,
you've got to have a major professional sport.
You know what I mean?
Sports team,
I would think so mean.
Who's can heal?
You're not,
you're not a fucking major city.
You May,
you name me one fucking major city,
one major fucking city in the United States of America that does not have a
significant representation of,
uh,
professional sports and I will show you a be city.
Okay,
go ahead and do it.
I dare you.
Look at Portland,
Portland,
Oregon.
Not saying they're fat,
but they got what?
They got a basketball team.
They're barely hanging in there.
What do they got?
They got the Portland Trailblazers.
They got hipsters in Portlandia.
That's all they got.
If one of those three things goes away,
that city is like bankrupt,
you know,
with their fucking food trucks and everybody just,
ugh.
Some of the grossest white people you're ever gonna meet in your life is in
Portland.
I don't know what,
uh,
what it is about.
You think it'd be Seattle?
You'd think they'd be more hippy dippy up there with all the fucking trees in
the rain and shit.
But I'm telling you there's something about Portland and I'm not saying all the
Portland,
I'm just saying most of Portland.
No,
I'm kidding.
You know what it is?
I still harbor resentment at that fucking city.
Cause one time they had this fucking place that was like the best pizza in the
fucking town.
He had to go across the god Damn River to where all the fucking hipsters are
going around with their big mustaches,
driving the fucking tricycles with a giant fucking wheel acting like they don't
realize there's better technology.
And I fucking go over there and the place was closed,
you know?
And I didn't go online like an asshole,
but I called the place,
you know,
that isn't good enough.
I just called the fucking place.
Somebody picked up,
hey,
you've reached fucking blah,
blah,
or hours of this did and then what?
I forget what that came about.
What the fuck it was.
And a,
I actually left a message,
I believe,
and I dropped a bunch of f bombs and shit.
And then afterwards I was like,
why did I do that?
It's not Portland's problem,
Bill.
It's your prom.
You fucking went online.
You saw with the good pizza places for,
but you didn't check the time.
So what did you do?
Not only did you curse him out in the machine,
you fucking turned around and you blame the entire fucking city when all you
were trying to do was say,
Houston,
Texas has a bunch of fatties in it.
Um,
hey,
if you live in Houston and you're fat,
do you feel proud,
like you're part of a gang or do you go,
do you feel shame?
Like God dammit,
I'm part of the problem,
you know,
I dunno.
What are you looking at?
Clio.
You're freaking me out.
One of the fucking dogs ears go up.
Then I wait and then she starts growler.
Houston's no longer the fattest fucking city
Amia.
Listen to this shit they said.
They say Houston's no longer the fattest city.
Right.
Come over here so I can talk to you.
I only got one microphone like a fucking asshole.
So they say Houston's no longer the fattest city.
Guess who they said they lost to
guess.
Guess what city they lost him.
He's done.
Who?
They lose two as the fattest city.
I feel like it's gotta be somewhere in the south.
Is that correct?
It is in the south.
Yeah.
There's no money to stay.
Just throw the fucking city up.
I don't know.
Somewhere in like Mississippi or Louisiana.
You fucking nailed it.
I stand corrected.
Shreveport,
Bossier city,
Louisiana.
They got that good food down there.
So
we got good food out here too.
Yeah,
but you know,
we're all concerned about Pilati is bodies and yoga and fitness and shit out
here in la.
That's not a priority out there.
Are you saying that people in Louisiana want to be fat and I say that they want
to,
I think they just have different priorities.
Do you support the troops?
Yes.
I think it's fucked up that a city that small can beat Houston,
Texas.
Oh,
okay.
Well why don't you think they're like in a different way?
Class.
Cool.
The fuck.
I never even heard it.
I've heard of Shreveport,
Louisiana,
but Shreveport,
Bossier.
Do they combine two fucking cities?
I have no idea.
I think it was fucking with Houston's tourism.
So they fucking paid off the,
uh,
the people that go around pinching people around the fucking country and they
go,
listen,
man,
you've got to get this shit off of us.
They get to the conspiracy.
You don't think that's weird that they lost to that.
You think the people of Houston has somehow not a politician.
Politicians
set up this,
this city,
Shreveport,
Bossier city in Louisiana and set them up.
Alright,
here you go.
You know what?
I'm going to check,
I'm gonna check the record right now.
Fattest,
fattest cities
last,
let's see.
We'll see.
I can't even spell last,
last 10 years.
Let's see what they say.
A fitness fetish is cities,
the 10 most obese cities in America.
Let's just see what this one has.
Yeah.
All right.
There's a good fed guy standing and they never show the fate face.
There's so much shame.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
I was wrong.
MEMPHIS,
Tennessee.
They've got a basketball team,
Shreveport,
Louisiana,
Indianapolis,
Indiana.
At a fucking cold fans.
You fucking pussies.
Jackson,
Mississippi,
New Orleans,
Chattanooga,
Tennessee,
mobile,
Alabama,
San Antonio,
Texas,
Greenville,
South Carolina,
Little Rock,
Arkansas,
thinness,
metro areas.
La Isn't on that.
Yeah,
but it goes from 91 up to 100 wow.
How come they don't show the,
Oh,
I see.
Because it's all part of the same fucking list.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of fatties out here and yet,
like Hollywood is in show business.
Everybody else is in La,
right?
Yeah.
So that you know everybody's fucking chowing down on Thai food,
Burgers,
burritos.
It's a lot of Fatty Saudia
in El.
I haven't.
Nice to see.
A lot of fatty is out here in la,
la.
Not really.
What does la La to you like Los Angeles County,
which is where?
I don't know.
Los Angeles County.
What am I?
A geographer?
I don't know.
Yeah,
no.
You're talking about Hollywood and you're talking about Santa Monica and Venice.
You basically from,
from basically here to to lax.
You don't see that many fatties but now I'm telling you,
you get out to the
my main,
but that's because you're right,
because of Hollywood.
It's just not a priority.
You get up to the inland empire near,
I'm telling you it's a shit show.
Is that I've never been to the inland empire.
No.
It's a shit show,
I e
that's right.
All right.
There's only one camp was on the market was only one microphone.
This isn't going to work.
Why?
Because it's just I gotta.
I gotta do this like I'm fucking Merv Griffin.
Like a Dick Cavett or something.
Yeah.
Well I can leave if that's what you,
is that what you're saying?
Well,
I'm in,
I don't know what to do here.
I just feel like the podcasts is slowing down of a sudden it got really hot in
this room because the AC is not on and all of a sudden you bring two people
together,
sitting side by side.
It starts getting uncomfortable.
Maybe this is what people in Houston need to do.
Sit next to each other.
Maybe burn some fucking pounds off.
All right,
so the thinnest metro areas,
um,
I guess they just did 100 cities,
right?
The fattest city.
So the finish guys,
where I guess for 91 to 100 is Tucson,
Arizona,
Denver,
Colorado.
Despite all the weed,
they gotta be shipping it out.
You figure what all the munchies they be getting up there.
They be getting,
they are getting,
I can stop watching your shows.
Colorado Springs.
It's true.
San Francisco,
California,
Boston,
mass.
Get the fuck outta here,
Bud light kid.
Um,
Sacramento,
California,
Los Vegas.
Get the fuck out you or cause they got a bunch of tourists now there's a robot
up there.
They don't count them.
Tourists on the strip.
The Jean shorts.
Oh yeah.
Maybe the people that work in the casino and not too many fatty is working in
the casinos and stuff.
Now they starved those people.
Plus when you get your hand broken that many times for cheating,
then they make your work there.
It's really hard to get a sandwich up to your lips like it's not the movie
casino anymore.
Boise,
Idaho,
Reno,
Nevada,
and last Honolulu,
Hawaii.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
by the way,
I,
it's way worse now.
Now that the is run it rather than the mob,
the mob,
all they took was the gambling.
The gave away the shows in the food.
Now it's like the corporations,
they fucking remember back in the day like Vegas,
she can get a steak for like three bucks.
She can't do it anymore.
You cannot do it.
Not even a Mcdonald's.
All right.
Yeah.
We literally just taking everything from casino and applying it like you
actually know what you're talking about when it comes to the history of Vegas.
Is that what I was doing?
I thought it was the Black Jack dealer.
Then I met the first time I worked out there.
Oh,
was it bump?
I mean,
I've played that place like 20 fucking times.
You talked to all the old dealers.
I always go,
hey,
no,
it's not the same.
It's not the same.
And if you get just keep fucking work and that's what they end up saying.
Say we made me way more money when the mob ran it.
People having a better time.
It wasn't the shit show of fucking kids with like the carriages and all that,
you know?
Yeah.
But the mob was running it.
Oh,
so the,
the,
the what?
The corporations,
all the corporations is there just on the legal side of stealing their,
oh,
I see.
Wow.
Okay.
When are you going to play there again?
Let's go back.
I Love Vegas.
Vegas.
Really?
Every time you go there like three days and you're like,
oh my God,
I gotta get Outta here.
Yeah.
I mean I cap at three days in Vegas and then I can't,
I can't do anymore.
Well then what's the point of me bringing it out there?
Because you go for a weekend.
I get to come.
What?
What does,
what are you talking about?
Well,
if you going to be all grumpy three days into one grumpy when I'm three days
into what?
I have my fun and then I'm,
then it's time to go.
Go shopping,
go see a show.
I hate that part of it.
Okay.
I hate when you go and then I have to go shopping.
Who goes to Vegas to go shopping?
Oh my God.
Thousands of people go to Vegas shot kinds of people.
Like everybody that goes there.
Why do you think they have all those stores in Vegas?
Because the cooperation's took over and they got all these bottom feeders that
want to fucking go around and buy something,
but dazzled Jean shorts don't wear for Dassel Jean show.
You call me a bottom feeder.
Everybody shops in Vegas,
Bill.
It's a thing that happens.
It's because you're in your little like cave of like you're in the room like Eh,
Eh,
for six hours and then you go on stage.
You're like,
wow,
wow.
And that's all you know about it.
You're talking about,
I hit the gym,
I hit the gym.
Yeah.
You go to the gym and they'll put out by the pool and you're pacing around the
room.
Like,
I have something to eat.
I'd go to have a drink.
I can't.
I mean I got to do a fucking show.
I gonna stay sober.
Well I'm letting you know that people go shopping.
Like what are people doing for the most part when we walk around their shopping
there at the salon.
I used to be for adults near.
Okay.
And you went there with your buddies and you met some broad,
I'm sorry,
correctly.
I'm sorry.
Did you participate in this heyday of Vegas that you seem to be like reminiscing
over?
Cause I really don't feel like you were a part of it.
I wasn't.
So then what are you getting all fucking nostalgic about?
Oh,
used to be you could do this and do that and get a shrimp cocktail for 5 cents.
Nobody cares bill.
No,
because I missed it because it was this great time and I missed it.
And then I went out there and it was just like every fucking place else should
go to every fucking strip malls,
the same fucking 10 stores and instincts.
And I've done the road long enough to remember when you went to a city and it
looked a little bit different.
It wasn't forever.
21 the fucking cheesecake factory.
Starbucks and fucking whatever you,
Taco Bell.
You know,
I seem to recall a time when we were in Vegas and we went to the shops at the
crystal shops at the Aria and there was a particular store that you went into
and you did some damage and you enjoyed it very much.
Do you not remember this?
No.
What did I do?
Do you want me to say in the name of the store?
No,
but what the what?
The why once Jesus Christ,
it's like you're going to see me for rest of the day.
I did some damage.
Yeah,
you did.
Oh,
and I bear bought a pair of shoes.
You bought a few.
Remember there's no way about one,
two pairs of shoes or you bought two pairs of shoes right?
Then let's not it back to that cause.
Well,
but it was at a particular place.
It wasn't like you at the men's Wearhouse outlet,
let's put it that way.
So when I had a fucking show to do it.
I'm just saying you're acting like you're so above the whole shopping in Vegas
thing like I'm not talking about buying a for some fucking adult God damn shoes.
I'm talking about walking around in your flip flops with your giant fucking ads.
What's he call it?
The stupid long plastic drinks and you wacky hat and you're fucking Jean shorts
and none of the cons gamble anymore.
They all just walk around and fucking looking for a buffet.
It's like fucking seaworld without the captive animals.
It's the fat fucks.
I can't stand it.
It's terrible.
You don't like Vegas?
I don't like that aspect of it.
I don't like watching people pushing their fat fucking kids around in strollers
at three in the afternoon past a slots and I was like,
what the fuck are you?
Why are you exposing your kids to all of this shit?
The only people who still fucking throw down in Vegas or our agents,
they're the only ones.
They're not fat.
They go right to the gambling table and they fucking sit there all day and they,
they get cleaned out or they fucking take the casino and then they go back to
their fucking whatever the hell.
Like you know the jets,
they'll do the only ones who do it right.
I have no idea how Asians do Vegas.
You never see those guys sitting at the,
the,
what does that Kino and then the Burt baccarat tables,
whatever the fuck it is.
You know,
I don't gamble.
Whatever the fuck it is.
They were always in the high stakes from crushing it.
Every one of them.
There's certainly not shopping,
right.
Well they're not shopping.
Can you have a little bit of fun Leah and stop turning everything to this
politically correct.
We'll have,
sure.
There's was a little dude and if a book and plastic drink,
I'm sure any,
I'm sure there was somebody from fucking Cuba in there too.
Plain,
Burt Bacharach,
whatever the fucking game is to say the tress.
Nice.
I'm trying to complement.
They dressed nice to sit down,
like gentlemen,
that women are back in the room with a fucking belong and then they sit there
and they Campbell.
It's a wonderful thing.
What are you think about Corey Hart and whatever and him,
Corey Hart,
he wears his sunglasses at night.
Yeah.
What about him?
I Dunno.
It's a big week for quarries.
I figure I'd give him a shout out to,
oh,
are you talking about that Corey Feldman performance?
Yeah,
that was,
I feel bad for that guy.
I feel bad too because you laughed.
I giggled.
Sure.
Charcoal.
Charcoal,
absolutely.
But the thing about it is he and his band or whatever it is,
they had a platform to do a show on a national performance on a national TV show
and you take it,
if you're an artist,
like that's what you do.
You get the exposure,
you know,
I don't understand why that everyone's trashing him.
He's just up there doing the thing and like,
it's so funny,
his relationship with Michael Jackson is still like so strong to this day that
he's still doing the Michael Jackson moves that Michael taught him like so many
years.
Yeah,
but so is Michael.
Michael,
did those moves probably for an extra decade,
too long,
wouldn't you say?
No,
he could do those forever,
but it's,
it's,
I dunno if she showed the socks a little bit too long.
If he ask me,
well what was he supposed to do?
All the kids some fucking pants to reach the floor like the rest of us.
He was on his own level and Corey was doing his thing.
I mean his band definitely,
they're dressed up like angels from like a party city costume angel.
They like,
it's just,
it was a bad look for the rest of is set up.
He could've just had maybe a little set of mater.
You think they set them up?
They do that every fucking roast.
If you ever watched the roast on comedy central,
there's always like,
what the fuck is that person doing there?
And what they are is they are raw meat because the person who's getting roasted,
if you have to go seven,
eight ninth,
10th there's hardly any jokes left,
but they just bring somebody in there like Ann Coulter.
The last time it was like,
oh my God,
I can't believe.
I mean they were to her,
it was like she was,
she was that person.
Every fucking roast.
They Kurt Cobain's wife.
One time I remember carrot top took a pounding one time.
There's always that one person who shows up excited like,
oh,
this is cool.
They invited me and then three minutes in,
Oh,
I'm this person.
Right?
Well that's what they did to Corey.
I'm sure he's fine.
Ultimately that they really need to book him.
They didn't.
Why did they book them?
They set them up.
The whole thing was a fucking set up and now the dudes sitting in his bedroom
with the curtains drawn and the fucking lights out,
they set them up from day one.
He was the Lee Harvey Oswald of fucking people who still do the robot.
I felt bad for him.
He'll be fine.
He needs to book small little venues around La and people will come and see him
there.
That's like want hipsters would go down there to laugh at him,
you know what I mean?
And not notice if the wax in their own mustache,
which she got going there buddy.
What do you mean you're be a beverage?
There have been a nice little,
a nice little nip.
Yeah.
You know I did.
I did Burt crushers.
Fucking uh,
200 podcast episode with Tom Segora.
Yes.
Um,
and I just had a theory about Miller high life bottles.
Like I refuse to believe that this 12 ounces of beer in here,
it looks like an eight ounce bottle.
I don't know what the fuck is going on with this thing.
You have three sips.
God.
Wow.
Maybe you're just drinking them really bad ass.
No,
but if I have a Budweiser,
it was like,
I feel afterwards,
I feel like,
wow,
that was refreshing and felt like 12 ounces when I drink Miller high life.
I'm like,
where the fuck did it go
down your gullet there.
You freckled fucking Pelican.
All right.
I'm going to finish this,
this podcast,
the questions,
the questions are on Monday and Thursday.
Thursday.
I just,
I'm just checking in on on,
yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
What do you want?
Anything you have to say to work in America?
Uh,
yeah.
Keep on keeping on.
I don't know.
Wow.
That was probably the,
that was the anti inspirational speech.
What do you mean it's Thursday?
They getting paid today.
All they got is one more fucking day.
Yeah.
All right.
Have a good weekend.
I'm terrible at this.
I don't know.
You're all fucking rainbows and hearts.
She's supposed to be positive.
What do you,
what do you got for America during an election year and Nia.
Oh my God.
Just pressure.
Just don't,
just,
don't screw this up everybody.
Yeah,
please.
Come on.
Let's all do our part.
You know what I'm talking about?
Hyping them for their weekend.
Oh,
I heard you were talking about the political clubs saying it's an election year
and these people need some Joe Sixpack near the gout dairy.
He puts his pants on one leg at a time.
Everybody puts their pant leg on one leg at a time.
Not the way Joe six pack.
Does it stop trying to act like somebody that works in blue collar is putting
their pants on different than anybody else.
Give me a break.
We're all putting in bathroom.
Are you saying you don't support Blue Collar America?
I do support blue collar America.
I the poor blue collar America.
How do you feel about,
uh,
toddlers all love them.
What if they're going to grow up and be blue collar people?
Would you still love him then?
I love him even more.
I'd buy them a little baby construction hat and the little metal lunchbox.
It's sick.
What if one of them is going to be a gay construction worker?
Oh,
even better as it's sang in a band.
Yeah.
I'm still a guy who appropriated native American where?
Well sang about a gym.
Sure,
but showed his chest hair.
We're talking about the village people.
No.
Oh,
I thought that's what you were going.
No,
I was talking sung about the people who are going to rebuild the La memorial
coliseum and a cop.
Well,
who are all the characters in the village?
People,
all I remember was a cop,
the native American,
a construction worker,
because there were all these like hyper masculine tropes.
Right?
So they were all like,
no,
they weren't.
Those are legitimate fucking jobs.
Yeah,
I know,
but that's what,
it's not a trope.
Okay.
Building a building,
leading the tribe against fucking Custer.
Oh,
rights.
And I'm just saying that they were all these like archetypes that they were
representing.
They were the construction worker,
the cob at the police,
uh,
Indian.
She disagree.
Disagree in 100% of those were gay men.
And I think what they were dressing up was their version of the French maid
outfit.
Like if they got a prostitute,
like I'd have a French maid come over and they'd have a guy dressed up.
Like he worked at ups.
I think I was reading something about this.
This is why I'm getting this from,
oh,
so this isn't your idea.
Oh,
but presented as yours.
I fully,
I fully admitted.
No,
he didn't.
You presented it for the last 30 seconds as though it was yours.
And then once I backed you into the corner with my Miller highlife fueled
brilliance.
Mm.
So what was the other,
what was the other person in skating?
The issue skirting issue there.
Okay.
Because I don't care anymore about arguing with you on this.
When you take into toys home,
taking my ball and going,
I'm going home.
And we still gonna be friends tomorrow.
Yes we are.
Who was the other one?
Come on.
Help me out.
Cop Construction worker.
Indian chief and mailman.
Mm.
Oh,
you almost know
electrician school teacher.
Gym Teacher.
Was there only four of them for the why?
MCA.
No,
I don't.
I don't,
I don't know you can we look it up?
I want you to do is just tell these people that have a nice fucking weekend.
Next thing you know I got,
I got to figure out,
all right,
let's have a bet here.
Up here.
This is a bet.
The closest without fucking going over,
you gotta be the closest to the job.
Cop,
cop,
Indian,
Indian chief.
And what your guests.
God,
I'm going to say federal judge
village people.
Here we go.
Fire.
I know I'm googling images.
Oh fuck.
I see what it is.
You see what it is?
It's a biker and all,
but there's also this guy,
oh wait,
oh,
a share.
I almost said sheriff.
Where's,
what do you see?
A sheriff,
bye.
Or Indian?
Native American.
Nick cow boy.
Cow Boy.
Have what?
Police officer.
Construction worker.
Army Guy.
I think that's the new one.
Not here.
He is the original idea.
You had the cowboy,
the,
the native American chief had an army guy,
construction guy,
biker and a cop.
I don't think anybody's having any more fun than the construction work.
Sometimes he's a sailor.
He's saying it was the same theme.
It's all these like
manly men.
Yeah.
Likely heroes from movies and stuff.
Yet they were all blown each other.
Right.
So America learned something,
didn't they take that America and the YMC a all right.
Nia,
I gotta I gotta do some advertising here at some point.
So I also had some other shit that I wanted to talk to other than the jobs of
the village.
Okay.
Well this has been fun.
So,
oh,
you really wanted to do it.
All right,
I'll leave it down here.
Alright.
I think we're going to talk about,
hey,
what'd you think about the red sox sweep in the Yankees in September?
That never used to happen when I was a kid.
I haven't watched all year,
by the way.
And we also have to play them against you.
They've got a good squad though.
I fucking love it.
You fucking love it,
dude.
Goes thoughts.
Yeah,
I think we're like two,
three games up.
I have no fucking idea.
All I know is we've won like a one,
four,
four in a row against the Yankees in the first two against the Orioles.
So on a six game winning streak.
And now if I keep talking about people going to say that I,
uh,
that I jinxed him,
but here's the thing.
Thursday night,
this evening,
okay.
Uh,
the Patriots are playing the Houston Texans.
All right?
And,
uh,
if Garappolo it's still hard.
If he can't go,
then Jacoby preset is going to be in from NC state.
But if he gets hurt,
Adelman,
our wide receiver who used to play quarterback of like Kent State or some shit
who saw one pass is a prone,
it's like a 50 yard pass,
the fucking Amygdala for a touchdown.
This is what bill Bellacheck is looking at.
If he goes three and now he beats them and we're three and now he's the greatest
fucking coach of all time without a doubt.
When I love is that the colts with their little ticky tack fucking big babies,
that they got their asses kicked by the Patriots,
that they weighed the balls and they just kept pushing with this fucking
suspension and they got to suspension and all it's going to prove is that
they're fucking cry babies.
And that Bill Bella check is the greatest head coach of all time.
When you think about that,
does any of that matter to you?
If it matter to you,
honey,
then it matters to me.
I sound like the chicken coming to America.
Whatever it is you like.
What's your favorite food?
Would you like?
You got to do the vow,
whatever.
Food.
July.
Yeah.
All right,
so what?
Ooh,
oh hop on one leg.
I didn't,
I,
you know,
I didn't think she was that much of a looker.
You know,
I can see why you would go to Queens.
Dare say that about Vanessa Bell Calloway to it's fine as hell was every hot
black chick in the 80s name Vanessa?
No does too.
There was the one who was in the beauty pageant who showed a tit Taiz and she
got dethroned.
Yeah,
that's one.
Does that chick from coming to America?
No.
Calloway.
Yes.
And then there was Vanessa bell at the time and then there was the other
Vanessa,
was there ever Vanessa much one bill?
Wasn't that the woman who played j sister and good times?
I don't know who that is in her character's name.
Vanessa.
I don't know.
Are you talking about the Huxtables and the Cosby show?
There was a Vanessa that was a character named I was a kid too,
right?
Yes.
It's creeping up now.
Just became creepy.
All right.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know what it is.
He's not on here.
I'm struggling here.
You know when they see on there is a way to have the AC on down here.
I don't know how to do that down here and I don't give a shit.
Do you want me to do it?
Nobody knows something.
I was clearing out,
you know,
cause it basically,
they're redoing our kitchen so they found this fuse box and it's like this
cloth.
The Guy said that our fusebox was from the Christopher Columbus days and I
laughed and I said,
I knew when you went into that fucking wall that that's what was going to be in
there.
So I had to move all this shit off the bookshelf from the other side.
And now all of it though,
or just part of it,
all of the I three of the four things,
you know,
it's funny on the bookshelf that very few books,
it's all magazines,
right?
All my drum magazines,
I am,
I just tapes from the 80s they need to get rid of.
I do.
There's a lot of shit I got to get rid of.
Do you know I have modern drummer,
like I have a box of all bunch of modern drummers from like 1982 to like 1993.
So here's my question for drummers out there.
Then I have up,
then I stopped from like 95 to 2000.
Then I have like everyone from 2000 to now and I'm thinking of just getting rid
of them cause I never go back and look at it.
But I know that are people that collect them.
So I think I'm going to get rid of them.
But the ones from 83 to [inaudible] 92 I'm keeping those.
Yeah.
Cause like I get some old,
like Steve Jordans.
I got to Vinnie,
Kali,
Uta,
I got to fucking Stuart Copeland.
Yeah,
I got an Alex van Halen one.
What are you going to take?
I got to Phil Rudd.
I got a Tommy Lee when he was still teasing up his hair.
But do you,
where are you going to take them?
I've got to Phil Collins.
They're going to a music,
Simon Phelps.
The goodwill.
Uh,
I've got Chris Slade.
What did they come to the goodwill or do you take him to like a a music shop?
Like an old drum shop?
I would put them up on Ebay and uh,
people would
like people bid on that Shit,
don't they?
I got a bunch of those,
a bunch of old drum magazines.
The ones that I really liked,
the interviews that I like and I liked their drum kits and shit.
Like a lot of Alex van Halen ones.
Those ones that I keep,
but they all the ones,
there's a bunch of people from back then I can look at Jeff Porcaro.
I got a lot of cool ones from way back in the day.
All right,
Ebay.
Here we go.
Am I boring?
You
know,
say one,
one,
one happy fucking thinking about the weekend.
You know,
talk about the,
the,
you know,
go out on a lake,
get out your jet ski,
spend time outside in the out of doors with your iPhone right now with a drone,
with your loved ones.
All right.
Modern drama.
Who was on the cover of the first one?
Yeah,
Tommy Lee.
Now.
It was 1978 Tommy,
he was still living at home,
buddy rich?
No.
Oh,
Jesus says there's a John Bonam.
When I have that one.
That one's what?
49 nights where it's 50 bucks animal from
the doctor teeth and the electric company or whatever that band is called or any
of these guesses.
Right.
Have they ever put animal on the cover weight?
Have they ever,
whoa.
Collection of modern drummer magazine,
260 issues.
320 copies from 1978 to 2005 500 bucks.
No one's buying that the fuck you talking about $500 for the whole whack
from 1978 to 2005 yeah,
it's like a dollar each.
All right as well.
So you got somebody is really going to spend that much.
Oh look at this old June,
1978 the month and year I was born Hustler magazine for nine 95 Oh,
that's a famous cover that people hate.
Wait,
click on that.
The Hustler magazine from June [inaudible] 78 which is when I was born.
Yeah.
Oh,
he says we will no longer hang women up like pieces of meat.
I didn't know that they have this woman getting put into a hamburger grinder
that that's,
that's just deliberately just steering into,
try and be in shock and you know,
yeah,
I'm sure they really didn't do that to somebody.
I don't think so either.
All right.
This,
did they ever put animal on the cover of modern drummer magazine or as modern
drummer magazine,
too serious of a magazine to do and that's have fun with that.
I don't recall them ever doing that,
but a lot of,
a lot of people have used animal as a reference,
like his five,
like they put animal on the cover and then they profile the person who does like
the music for when they do animal monitor magazine.
I think I'm onto something with this,
but as,
I don't know that they ever did that.
Animals too dated maybe.
Yeah.
I don't know that they ever did that,
but it was a lot of people that,
uh,
I remember the guy from God smack said,
you know,
that he was an influence.
This is all vibe.
He was a fucking loan to tick.
Um,
so anyways,
look at,
I've got to do some advertising here near,
this is basically the end of the podcast.
Oh,
I finally saw highlights of the Singapore,
a Formula One race.
They did it at night.
Now I've got that recorded back at the house.
I hope now that they shut off the power that I'm not going to lose all of that.
But the race is actually at night.
And Nico Rosberg one again,
he's won the last three.
He wanted that one.
He went to Italy.
Anyone Belgium.
Pretty fucking killer.
How'd you go back to Singapore in order to see that?
Absolutely.
What an animal would do a show at a great shoulder.
Yeah.
I love Singapore.
It was too sterile for you.
You know how I feel about Singapore?
Yeah.
It wasn't my favorite place.
Okay.
You just thought it was too,
too rigid?
I did.
I thought that it was a,
well,
what I've said is out of hand sanitizer were a country,
it would be Singapore.
So it was just a little too clean.
It was a little too perfect.
It was sort of like everything is part of everybody that got a spanking,
but at what cost?
Yeah,
exactly.
Like it just seemed like,
I don't know,
it was just,
it was,
uh,
I made me,
I should give it another chance,
but I just didn't feel entirely,
I wasn't,
yeah,
maybe just,
just stay here in la.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't need,
you know,
fly all around to these places and you're going to complain about it.
We went to Hong Kong after what?
I loved.
Hong Kong.
Dope.
Singapore.
Yeah.
This wasn't my vibe.
You didn't have to say that.
Okay,
well you asked me,
so what,
what are you going have tense about?
Yep.
You know what?
I swear to God when you do that gas lighting,
what does that is that thing?
Where is that being weird?
Okay.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It's that thing where you,
you throw something out at somebody they react to and you were like,
yeah,
Whoa,
whoa.
What's the problem?
Make them think that they're crazy.
You do that to me.
If I should a deal like a,
do you like it?
Cantaloupe.
You're like,
I never want to know fucking candle up again.
I have a right to be like,
whoa.
Hey,
it's just a fruit
that happens.
You're doing it again.
You're the king of gaslighting you.
You make me think I'm crazy.
You bring up something
I don't believe in Kingston.
Yeah,
I think we're all the same.
I don't think there are kinks.
I think we're all citizens.
Thanks.
Why don't we just said I was the king of gas lighting.
I just saying I'm just just a citizen.
Yeah.
Hmm.
You do do re do divide a lot of people into groups.
Yes.
That's the only way to get out.
Then you just have to stare into it.
Like if you ever get on like CNN or Fox News and their bill O'Reilly Web.
Who's CNNS bill O'Reilly,
the guy with the and Cooper.
Yeah.
When they back into the corner.
So you saying you don't like babies or ice cream,
you know it's gotta be like,
yes.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
Terrible on those shows.
I ain't get off lesser nights and giggling and it wouldn't be good at those.
Those talking head things,
those making those serious political
points now.
Yeah,
but that's only because you don't know what you're talking about.
Oh,
thank you.
Well,
that's maybe a little bit,
you don't,
we don't watch the news.
I do watch the news.
You don't read.
Excuse me.
I do.
What do you read?
The newspaper?
You never read a newspaper?
I read the newspaper online.
I don't read like the physical newspaper.
Andy Cohen daily.
No,
I go to fucking the New York times.com cnn.com and take your hand off your
hip.com.
Well,
I don't ever see it.
Yeah.
You know when we sit there and we eat quietly and you didn't see the sign of our
silverware hitting the plate,
you never just say,
hey bill,
do you know in Indonesia,
blah,
blah.
No,
we don't really do we talk a little bit about current events?
What do we talk about at dinner?
Nobody cares.
This is all about me trashing you for no apparent reason and gaslighting me.
Do you remember what that means?
I know what a guest ladies.
I know.
Gino.
The understand what I mean?
Make them a New Orleans because the gas light somebody,
did they make them in the fattest city in the world?
No.
New Orleans,
New Orleans is definitely getting there.
My experience,
fattest airports I've ever been to.
Okay.
Lax Bunch
of tourists coming through really wider lens through.
They want to go see Walt Disney's fucking castle.
Yeah,
they do.
They want to put on their fucking mouse ears and fucking ever a cheese steak
wrapped in cotton candy and just shove it down their throat and then blame
somebody else for their obesity.
You know what I mean?
You have though.
You totally have the fucking power.
This is when you know you're getting fat.
When you put salt in your cantaloupe,
it's just like,
can you just eat the fruit?
It's people wrap her shooto into cantaloupe.
It's like he can't even have a piece of fruit without the wrapping and fake it.
Like you can get that in Italy.
Prosciutto in Milan.
It's like a thing that they do.
Don't ever say Malone again.
It's Milan sailing in American Milan,
Milan load change stone.
Is that how they say in America?
Prosciutto and melon is a thing that you can get an Italy.
It's not an a fat American thing
at all.
So wrong.
All right.
Try it again.
Yeah.
All right.
You know what,
Neil,
I think this is the end of the podcast.
How about that?
We're just checking in on you.
They need to read some advertising.
Yeah,
but it's not here yet,
so I want to do it on my phone and now I have to go look at a episode
eight and 10 of season two of afters for families coming together.
Nini.
It's going to be really,
I think it's going to be funny.
We'll see.
We'll see what the people say.
They're um,
all right.
Did set goals
patch or bats bill Bellacheck could possibly,
if he hasn't done it already solidified himself as the greatest fucking
coachable time.
Head coach of all time and a red sox.
Keep winning.
It's great.
Then the Bruins and Celtics startup,
it's a great time of year near get involved.
Stop watching those real housewives.
There's nothing real about them near other than the sad look in their botox
frame dies.
There was look sweaty.
This shiny faces.
God is she gonna Puca to,
she literally puked up a cactus today.
It's higher like hundreds of blades of grass.
Yeah.
And you found it and then you try to drag me into it.
Oh my God.
Look what she did.
Yeah.
We'll pick it up.
Oh,
hey did.
And I cleaned it.
All I asked you to do was to put it on the fucking balcony.
So good air out in the sun rug cleaning.
Yeah.
What a fuck the one,
what am I going to do?
Because I needed your help to do it.
That's why I fucking ridiculous.
I all I know is when I find fucking puke dog puke.
I just pick it up.
I don't go down the hall.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
I can believe it.
The dog eats grass like a fucking cow for whatever reason.
And now that we brought that up,
there's gonna be a thousand people going.
We don't see [inaudible] up.
Shut up.
You're not a veterinarian.
All right.
That's been the Thursday afternoon caucus.
I would read a little advertising,
then we'll have some music,
so don't step on that.
Um,
and then we'll have some greatest hits from a podcast going by.
Also checkout Berg crushers.
200th episode with Burt.
Of course,
myself and Tom said Gora alright,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
All right.
Little bit of advertising.
He had clubbed Debbie,
how good old friends club Debbie when she going to do now you can feel for
current.
You going to vote to Hillary convenience club,
Debbie,
I put the trunk delivers wine straight to your door.
Personalized.
Uh,
we send you wine that is personalized to your palate and taste to our pallet.
Quiz or recommendations become even more personalized with every bottle you rate
a unique,
we work with top wine growers,
man and growers from all around the world directly to make all of our own wine
high quality and value.
Okay.
Are $13 bottles would normally retail for 20 bucks.
It's kind of pedestrian.
If you asked me no risk,
you choose the type and quantity of bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation.
You know a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
We partnered with local artists to develop wine labels that are unique works of
art.
Take the pallet quiz,
register for an account.
You should have a promo code and an email sent to you.
Bye Charles.
At Art.
What am I supposed to read there?
Right now club Debbie
is offering listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go to club w.com/burn it gets even better,
even better than Q and stem.
I know you all hate paying for shipping some club.
Debbie,
what happened with him?
Felonies,
I wouldn't go to the gym.
We'll actually pay for your shipping on orders of four bottles and more.
So take something off your to do list and just go to club W.
Daddy,
who's your slippers club?
[inaudible] dot com slash bird and get $20 off your first order.
Now this club,
shop and tear around the world club,
w.com/bird all right,
lastly,
but not leastly legal zoom.
You've heard the expression time is money,
right?
No.
Well where the fuck are you been?
Cause it's true.
Especially when you run a business.
You can't afford to waste time taking.
You're taking care of your legal needs.
That's why you need to use legal zoom.
If you work with the typical attorney,
they'll charge you for their time.
It's called the billable hour and a lot of the,
they won't tell you how long it will take.
Take an advance that's called the fuck over.
But legal zoom is different.
They're not a law firm.
They spent the last 15 years is making sure you get the most of your time.
Yeah,
and by building a useful website paired with amazing customer support for
efficient help and if you need advice,
legal zoom works with independent attorney licensed in 48 states.
Fuck Alaska and Hawaii attorneys who are more focused on helping you than
logging billable hours.
That's why millions of people have trusted legal zoom.
You can expect quality legal help on your schedule and flat fees instead of
expensive hourly rates and invest your time and money.
Then your business and use legal zoom for the legal stuff and save even more by
entering burn.
But you are in the referral box at checkout.
That's legal zoom.com yeah,
so [inaudible].
All right.
[inaudible] first thing first.
I'm over 21 years of age,
so no worries about giving advice to sit to a minor.
Recently my wife approached me and that's why we don't have a kegerator.
He's got a good one here.
He goes,
needless to say,
within minutes of that statement,
we now are the proud owners of a new kegerator and seeing as how I've been
married for eight years and this is the first time she's ever given approval for
a purchase prior to me buying it.
I'm pretty excited about this.
How do guys get themselves in that situation?
Unless she's making all the money and you've got to go to her for cash,
right?
Yeah.
I mean she seems cool unless she's got a drinking problem,
but that's awesome.
Yeah,
and I,
you know what,
I didn't even think of that.
Anyways,
however,
I really need some advice as to what kind of beer I should keep it stocked with.
Choosing the right beer is key to the process.
I'm afraid if I buy something like Amstel light,
all my friends will know.
My wife wears the pants in the family.
That's hilarious.
Cause he gets the calories less calories here.
Um,
if I buy us a stronger,
thicker,
more manly beer like Newcastle or Guinness,
I may also have to buy a wheelbarrow to wheel my friends out of the basement on
weekends.
And I really don't need that level of responsibility.
I can't do anything like Miller lite or course chords.
Like,
cause I might as well hook the tap up to the faucet.
That's true.
That's very true.
I said a long time ago,
the cores light,
that's like vitamin water for alcoholics.
Like all my friends.
Yeah.
Just,
you know,
I'm on the wagon,
I'm on the wagon.
You're like,
dude,
you're fucking drink.
It has cost life.
Um,
I narrowed it down to those seconds or Labatt blue.
The only thing with love black blue would be if any French Canadians find out
I'm fucked because you know,
those bastards would be knocking on my door seven days a week.
Uh,
what do you think,
Paul?
If you had to get a Kegger rater f if you had to get a k,
it sounds like this guy doesn't want to go domestic.
Uh,
but he also doesn't want to go really fattening Sam kill Sam Adams.
Yeah,
Sam Kid.
Maybe a nice parallel.
I would go,
uh,
I would just go classic.
It's a keg.
It's a fucking keg.
I would go pod rises.
That's such a weird thing for your wife to just purchase it.
Like to be like,
yeah,
you know what I got to like,
that's,
that's pretty fucking cool.
That's beyond cool.
That's weird.
Almost like Stacie came home,
I would just be,
yeah,
I've got this big wine rack.
I'd be like,
yeah,
she starts doing like little keg raters.
Headstands you know,
like,
you know,
they,
they did that,
but you have girl pushups.
She does like the girl version of what fucking keg stand.
What period would you put in there?
I get,
I get Budweiser because that's like a classic like who's going to come home?
What are you gonna come home like norm on cheers.
He just can start pouring yourself a big mug of beer,
you're going to be a tub of shit.
So I figured the only time you're really going to be porn like that is if you
have guys over for the game.
Budweiser is a nice middle of the road that everybody's going to like you drink.
But at the game it's not,
it's not one of the Light Beers shitting out like now that I'm like,
you know,
33 years old and stuff.
So my metabolism is obviously slowing down,
but I gotta be honest with you,
man.
When I drink three beers,
I feel like a fucking fat bloated.
I could feel my tits getting bigger.
I could.
You're about ready to entry.
Enter your whiskey and Scotch years.
Yeah,
I think so.
Do you get so because beer just gives me an output and then you get tired.
Whiskey.
If I drink a whiskey on the rocks now,
which is kind of whiskey.
Yeah,
yeah.
Scotch.
That's like a,
a,
a vaporizer for alcoholics.
Like you know,
vaporizer.
You have like vaporizer.
If you're going to smoke weed is the way to do it.
I would think because it,
it filters out everything except the shit that gets you high.
You take a hit off it,
it,
there's no burning sensation.
It's,
oh,
it's like a mist.
And I swear to God,
if you get high with a vaporizer versus drinking three or four beers,
like just the fatty tissue you're going to build on your liver.
Like I would think that a vaporizer is,
I mean obviously no research here because I'm an idiot,
but I,
I just,
by looking at it,
that's arguably the healthiest way to get fucked up.
You know what I mean?
What's the most healthy to drink?
What's more healthy?
I have no idea.
Well,
I would say for not being fat.
Look at,
if you,
if you get like a juice,
drink hard stuff and you drink it on the rocks or he'd just drink it neat.
And uh,
what people get fucked up is,
you know,
they,
they drink like Jack and cokes,
you drinking sodas all night and all those fucking like alcoholic words like
neat.
I would just,
okay.
Regular.
Yeah.
Neat is a no,
no ice.
That's just straight.
Okay.
And then rocks is obviously with some ice,
but you don't want to mix it with anything.
Like,
you know,
I guess,
twist of lime.
The older you get,
you just,
you just want to go right to the fucking,
you get right to the,
it's like how old old people fight.
If they're gonna fight,
they're not going to sit there and try it.
You know who used to do that bit like Richard Pryor,
somebody.
Then I got to look cool.
They think immediately tried to blow out your knee.
Just end the ship.
They'll kick in the balls.
They don't give a fuck.
That's the way old people drink.
Like I've heard somebody tell was a bartender said when somebody comes in,
if they order a beer,
I think,
okay,
this guy could be a problem.
But if somebody just comes in and they order like a whiskey or whatever and it's
this sitting there,
you know,
and they know how they want to think.
All right,
this guy's a pro.
He can handle himself as a rookie.
Yeah,
yeah.
Ugly.
Oh yeah,
he's coming in.
Let me get a,
you know,
give me get a shot exam.
Zam Buka couple.
Yeah.
You guys want to do shots?
You want to rattle those guys?
Yeah.
That's going to be,
it's like a car bomb.
As soon as you
do the carb on the dumbest thing,
the Irish carbon,
it's cool because it makes you drop Amaretto into a beer.
Is that what is the Sh isn't it?
It's a Guinness in and it's a shot up.
No,
not again.
It's,
it's uh,
maybe there's a bunch of alcoholics,
not gonna lie to the ends of his podcasts.
Got me Thursday.
I do it.
I'm ready to drink.
Yeah,
me too.
Like,
yeah,
no,
no.
What?
Booze and after this,
um,
yeah,
so Sarah,
I would go with,
but okay,
so he says those sec.
He's a Labatt blue.
You know what I would do,
I wouldn't do the sec is just because the most interesting man in the world.
It's a little overhype.
I go Labatt blue.
I think that's cool.
I have,
I can't remember what Labatt Blue Chase lakes.
Canadian,
right?
Yeah.
But does it have the extra alcohol once it comes in,
once it comes into triple x has the extra,
it's the sexiest got hurt.
The second dude,
that's another reason to fucking get into hockey.
When you go up to Canada,
when you drink that beer,
it has twice the alcohol content.
You know what just fucking Canadians are other than the fact,
they say they're peaceful and neutral,
everything,
but their sport is fucking by Barrick and they drink like fucking maniac.
They do and they're not peaceful either.
They're not.
That's just Michael Moore's version of what they are because it worked for his
documentary.
Did they lost a hockey game and they burned down the city.
Talk about an unacceptable face.
Exactly.
Michael Morris on the head of that,
I got,
I got fucking two words for Canada grow up.
All right,
here's another to act your fucking age.
I'll be in Edmonton at the,
Eh,
what's going on?
It's a bill and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 22nd I'm going to guess September 22nd is that what it is?
I Dunno.
You know why?
Because I have not looked at a,
uh,
a calendar in weeks.
Last time I remember looking at a calendar was at the punchline in San Francisco
and that's cause I started September 11th,
nine,
11.
You know,
obviously that date sticks out.
So let's do the math here.
So Thursday,
the next Thursday 11 and seven is 18 Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday,
Monday.
Yeah,
the 22nd.
There you go.
I just got back from a,
Oh this is actually the,
this is the first podcast in a couple of weeks,
an official podcast because something was going on with the g cast thing over
the,
uh,
I don't pass a couple of weeks,
which I tried to explain in a quick four minute thing the other day.
And basically if you didn't listen to that,
basically what happened was I would babble for half an hour,
like I always do.
And then I'd go to publish it and then they'd be like a,
there's been an error.
Good bye.
And it would hang up on me.
So that happened the last couple of weeks.
So if you are new to my page,
which I hope you walk cause I just had an hour long special that came out of
comedy central and I'm hoping to get some new people on here.
Um,
I do one of these podcasts every single week and um,
I have a new feature on the podcast or you people excited or the nine of you
still fucking hanging in there.
I had like 14,
and then I took two weeks off,
so I'm sure I'm on it.
We'll be on the fucking UPN now.
Does that even exist anymore?
Didn't they?
They combined the combined UPN and WB to make the WB UPN network or something.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
the new feature on my,
my podcast is you can finally subscribe to it.
I didn't realize that you couldn't subscribe to it,
which is actually a lie.
Somebody emailed me about six months ago saying that you couldn't,
and I ignored it because I don't like dealing with computers.
And uh,
so I guess I'm the Douche there.
But finally I redid my website,
[inaudible] dot com and if you go onto [inaudible] dot com don't do it now
because the podcast will shut off and start over again.
But um,
or you can't go there.
I don't give a shit.
I'm trying to drive people to go there anyways.
I have a new website,
Bill bird.com,
and when you go on that,
um,
there's some buttons and if you click on the Monday morning podcast,
you know,
once you open a new window and let me walk you through.
Okay,
go up to you little file button.
Set the one you want to hit.
You guys using a Mac like me.
Um,
you click on new window and then you go to bill bird.com.
It's going to be very instructional this week.
All right,
I'll wait.
I'll wait for you guys who have old laptops like me,
you know,
but there is one chick who tells me every week she listens to it at the gym.
Right now she's actually on a treadmill,
so she can't do it.
So just try to memorize this part.
Okay,
sweetheart.
Um,
I sound like a dick.
They're heritage sweetheart.
Why am I in Cherokee boy mood?
Um,
okay.
Sorry about that man.
No offense to the lady at the gym.
Now she's a lady.
Bill.
Now you're overly apologizing.
Okay.
Why don't you just meant that you're an angry psychopath and even when you're in
a,
in a,
in a good mood,
you still sound like a dick.
All right,
there you go.
High like that.
Honesty,
first day of the fucking week.
Um,
all right,
so if you go to [inaudible] dot com it's,
she lets you guys have opened your new window.
It's hopefully,
you know,
you can click on those buttons.
Um,
right underneath that black and white picture of me looking at somebody who is
annoying me while I'm on stage.
Um,
there's a button there that says Monday morning podcast and if you click on
that,
the podcast will come up and probably start over again,
which would be confused,
confusing.
Um,
I dunno,
you should be able to figure it out so you can,
you can subscribe on that page and you can,
you know,
download the shift to your iPod.
It's going to be available up on iTunes and I guess,
I don't know,
my web guy was trying to explain that.
I didn't really get it,
but I'm,
I'm,
what I'm basically trying to say here is so fucking bad at explaining shit is
you can finally,
this is what I should've said initially.
You can finally subscribe to my podcast by going to [inaudible] dot com clicking
on the button that says Monday morning podcasts,
or even the photo of me where it says Monday morning podcast,
the new window will open up and you just,
you can subscribe right there and I'll you computer savvy people can take it
from there.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
I got through it.
All right,
so that's the big thing.
And secondly,
I want to thank everybody.
Over the last couple of weeks,
all the people came out to the punchline in San Francisco.
The turnout was ridiculous.
I didn't even get any radio and all the shows sold out.
So I really appreciate everybody up in the bay area,
motherfucker.
And,
uh,
last week,
um,
at the Richmond funny bone,
I want to thank the 400 people,
451 people that actually paid to see me over the course of five shows.
I,
Oh God,
I had a brutal week out there.
I don't know that,
that fucking comedy club,
it's like the Bermuda triangle.
You know,
they got it in a,
in a mall behind a Dick's sporting good.
And for the life of me,
I can't get anybody.
I can't get anybody to come out to see me there.
It's unreal.
I was in New Jersey,
I sold out San Francisco,
sold out in New York.
I sold out,
I go to Richmond and all of a sudden it's like,
it's 1992 and I'm a brand new comedian and no one knows who I am.
But,
um,
the people who did show up and some people who just wandered in,
I'd be lying to you if I didn't say I had a good time.
I had a great time.
It was actually the first date on the uninformed,
uninformed tour with uh,
Joe to Rosa,
which is another thing that I have going on in my life right now.
I am doing a tour to hype my XM show called uninformed on Xm Two oh two,
uh,
with Joe to Rosa and well,
he's going to be on all my dates coming up.
Um,
the next one being,
uh,
the Cap City Comedy Club in Austin,
Texas and uh,
the DC Improv of whatever.
What am I doing here?
I'm just being,
I'm just like whoring myself out right now.
Um,
I usually get to the funny first and then in the end I put the,
uh,
the information.
So considering this,
this podcast started off so dry,
like a white wine that you might have after for some fucking fish.
Um,
you guys want to hear some hate mail car?
Should do.
Why would you want me to read a bunch of emails where,
uh,
people telling me that they think I'm funny.
That's not interesting.
All right,
so the other day I did a,
I did Conan O'brien.
Um,
definitely I did that on September 9th because the person who wrote the hate
mail let me know that it was nine,
nine oh eight when I did Conan O'brien.
And basically,
you know,
I gotta be honest with you,
it was the best four and a half minutes that I've ever had on a late night show.
You know,
I've done,
I mean it was,
I'd done,
I've done like three cars in dailies for Letterman's and this was my third Conan
and I finally figured it out how to do it.
You know,
cause the problem I have is my jokes are really long,
so I try to chop them up.
My jokes are also very,
um,
not conducive to running a crest toothpaste ad afterwards,
you know,
and I kind of look,
I kind of like,
I'm a dick and I have my area in haircut now,
so I got all that fucking going.
So I have to,
so I had to somehow figure out how,
and four and a half minutes to come out and make the crowd kind of go,
dude,
what the fuck?
Like,
I always do,
but somehow get them back quick enough where they'll like me for the next four
fucking minutes.
And I finally did it.
I finally did it wire to wire.
I fucking,
it was so fucking smooth that I was,
I got up,
I had absolutely no regrets.
I didn't think of anything that,
where I fucked up.
And I was thinking,
uh,
you know,
this I this thing once a,
well not even my mother would criticize it,
you know,
cause she always criticize him and uh,
she's not trying to be a jerk.
She's trying to what she says that she's trying to make it better.
Okay.
Which is what she's doing.
But,
you know,
it's kind of Nice to be like,
hey son,
you did a good job.
Oh by the way,
next time,
don't fuck this up.
You know,
you know,
ease into it.
You know,
you just don't hit me with a fucking straight,
right.
Like Ali,
you know,
the one,
one punch.
I didn't prepare for that.
My mother is going to fucking criticize me.
You know what I mean?
If I see that when we were kings,
when Ali's fighting George Foreman back when he was a,
a scary individual before he became this happy guy who had,
who makes grills or at least signs them.
Um,
I don't think it's in the factory doing it,
but uh,
yeah,
that's what he did,
came out the first round and he's like,
what's the one punch he hasn't prepared for the straight.
Right.
And he fucking bashed him in the face like nine times with it.
This is my mother is the verbal equivalent to a straight right
and that,
that God damn fight there.
Okay.
So anyways,
I did so great.
I,
she even left me a message.
She said it was so great.
I'm not,
I'm not even,
I could criticize it because it's kind of a joke between us because there was a
moment there when I wouldn't tell her I was on television because I couldn't
handle the fucking criticism.
All right.
That was a big long windup to say it went so fucking awesome.
But I still ended up getting some hate mail and here it is.
Basically what happened was I opened up with this adopting a dog joke cause I
want to get a puppy and people are telling me that I should rescue a dog.
And my worry is if I go down there,
you know,
I know there's a lot of good dogs down there,
but you know,
there's a couple of,
you know,
there's the COO,
Joe's and old yellers down there too.
So I'm kind of fucking nervous to do that.
So that's basically the joke,
right?
So this is the email.
This is the email I got from this lady.
She says,
Bill,
I cut your act on Conan tonight,
nine,
nine oh eight.
She has that in parenthesis to make it nice and official.
She goes,
uh,
I usually love the comedians.
He features on his show as I have watched his show every night for more than 13
years.
And I am known to have a good sense of humor.
So you see what she's done in the beginning.
She has established yourself as somebody who is a,
a regular viewer,
has not missed one show in 13 years.
That's pretty incredible.
Don't you think?
It's almost like it didn't really happen.
It's almost like she's setting me up so she can then be an unbelievable fucking
cunt.
Okay.
And then she's also known to have a good sense of humor and evidently that's
true cause she's,
she,
she wrote it,
she's known to have a good sense of humor by a bunch of other fucking people
that I don't even know,
but okay,
we'll take your word for it.
So she's known to have a good sense of humor and she goes however I'll,
is it going to take a left turn?
I think it is.
However,
I was completely appalled at your rant about rescue dogs.
You're horrible.
Unfair stereotypes is why millions of dogs and cats are killed each year at
Shell,
at the shelter and pounds in the USA.
Isn't that amazing?
I thought it was because a bunch of people dropped off dogs that they didn't
want anymore and then nobody adopted them.
And that's why they ended up getting killed.
Evidently it's because of the joke that I told on Conan O'brien.
So anyways,
many pets,
we're back to her now.
Many pets are left at shelters do to,
to do to the mortgage crisis.
And people have lost their homes or their owners dying,
not because they were bad dogs or repeat offenders as you compared them to
dangerous felons and prison.
See,
that even made me laugh.
That's a funny,
you know,
comedy is exact exaggeration.
So anyways,
she continues.
Hundreds of rescue dogs from local pounds have gone on to become huge movie
stars.
All right,
we're going to stop right there for a second.
Huge movie.
Stars should I keep,
so I keep ripping this apart and he wanted me to keep reading it.
I make this the last time.
I'll stop and I'll just finish the fucking letter.
Huge movie starts really,
Really Lisa.
Okay.
Let's name them lassie.
Benji,
I've heard of this.
Rin Tin Tin back in the days when fucking Milton Berle had a show,
right?
And then when he left with,
there's something you guys can email me and email me and some more famous dog.
Spuds Mackenzie.
That fucking,
uh,
why,
why the fucking thing from the Taco bell commercial?
What are your,
you'll cal it.
Taco Bell.
That one.
He's not even the same as,
he's like the fucking,
uh,
who's,
he's like,
you know what?
And that's all.
It's not even famous.
I was like the,
that is the dog equivalent to that dude.
He used to get on TV,
be like,
dude,
you're getting a Dell.
Remember him?
He was famous for like three minutes and then he bought some weed and Washington
square park and that ended that
huge movie.
Stars really?
When spots going to make us fucking comeback.
Is he in the next pulp fiction?
All right,
I'm going to just finish the letter here.
Cause this thing fucking drives me nuts.
Okay.
They've gone on to become huge movie stars and more have even become real life
heroes.
Saving many lives.
Making fun of people is totally up for grabs.
Making fun of homeless animals in shelters or pounds.
Waiting to die is like making fun of the Jews in German death camps.
Totally offensive.
Okay.
Can you fucking believe that this is the level she's taking this too?
You know,
I mean,
don't you think your justice offensive comparing Jews to shelter dogs?
We want to get hold of the mirror to your face.
Sweet.
I'll do it again.
I'm commenting.
Finish the letter bill.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
This is when it starts getting threatening.
Do you need to be reminded what happened to Ellen to generous when she publicly
denounced the rescue group on air?
Yes,
I do.
You dumb bitch.
She still has her own hit TV show.
Sorry.
Continuing.
She led,
she alienated herself from anyone that has adopted a pet or rescued a homeless
pet.
There are millions of us and she even offended,
responsible animal owners.
So what are you saying?
The other people who adopt those people,
homeless pets are not responsible.
So anyways,
she goes,
the outcry was tremendous and it hurt her popularity dearly.
Oh yeah.
I just saw an,
an American Express commercial.
She really looks like she's hurting
Jesus Christ.
She's probably fucking ordering whores every five minutes.
Seven we'll come over dressed like Dirk girl scouts,
you know?
All right.
Um,
I don't think this part of your act is going to go over well in Austin,
Texas.
Scratch.
She's on my website stalking me now.
I'm down in Austin,
Texas.
They are huge animal lovers and even bigger rescue animal lovers.
They even made city a no kill city for shelter and rescue animals.
And here's where she brings it down.
She takes it down to know we all need to laugh.
Just don't perpetuate stereotypes that harm the innocent and increase the death
rates.
Come up with something else.
As I recall,
no one hardly laughed until you changed the topic regarding Lisa.
Isn't that,
that's the part of the email that really fucking hurts the most.
Okay.
Is I not only that I finally have this great wire to wire set,
which I will be putting up on my website today.
Okay.
Um,
you know,
it went so well.
Not even my mother fucking criticizes it.
And then just out of left field.
Here comes Lisa.
Here comes Lisa who's so into this fucking topic that she compares dogs being
put to sleep to the Holocaust in Germany.
Now I'm a dog lover.
I went to what she does.
I'm a dog lover and a,
you know,
I'm known to have a good sense of humor,
but you know what the fuck lady,
why don't you take it down a little bit?
Okay.
Making Fun of those dogs is the equivalent to what Michael Vick did in fucking
Virginia.
Maybe where that's another human being who was doing mean shit.
The dogs,
I can see that.
You know,
I don't think me making fun of dogs is the equivalent of somebody trying to
exterminate an entire race of people so he can take over the fucking world.
All right?
And no point that I say to make lamps out of a cocker Spaniel either.
So your comparison is fucking ridiculous.
Okay.
Now we're into paragraph to Ellen to generous,
okay.
The worst thing that happened happened out of that was everybody made fun of her
for crying.
You know,
radio shows,
talk,
show hosts.
They all made fun of her,
but she's doing fine,
okay?
She comes out,
she does a little fucking,
uh,
Irish Jig at the beginning,
which is fucking cringe worthy.
And I cannot even watch it,
you know?
And after a while,
you know,
when you do it,
90 shows in a row,
it's almost like you feel like the higher ups are telling her to do it and she
doesn't want to dance anymore.
So I really tried to look into her eyes to see like that cry for help.
Um,
and I don't know what the fuck you talking about the joke not going over Lisa,
you know,
went over great.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It was awkward until I said,
why don't we just go down to a prison and an adopt an inmate and roll the dice
that the guy was wrongly convicted.
Bam right there.
I got my first laugh and then I just wrote that out.
Like Blake,
one of the fucking beach boys took it right to the god Damn Beach.
All right,
so why don't you just fucking lighten up a little bit,
you know,
get out of your agenda for a second.
Okay.
And,
and,
and watch my set again because it was a fucking great set.
Got Damn it.
And I'm going to put it up on my website today cause I finally got the cliff.
If it's approved to people and you can see what she's talking about it first,
it starts off awkward,
but I mentioned that that's how my sets always start off.
All right.
I'm an opening recently with a line in my ex Sam,
sick of obese people crying on TV now.
That always causes people to pull back.
It's a great way to get people to shut the fuck up and look at this stage before
you ease them down into whatever thing you want to talk about.
So that's how I did on Conan.
Alright,
actually I got gonna miss you guys.
I was actually standing backstage,
sitting there going like,
oh my God,
I'm open.
I'm opening up making fun of rescue dogs.
I'm going to come off like a psycho.
And I was second guessing myself and then I was just sitting there like going,
really?
Are you really gonna do this again?
You're 12th late nights sent.
Why don't you,
you always do that.
You do that in comedy clubs.
So what I did was I walked out there and I just said,
fuck it.
And I just play to the crowd.
Like I was in a comedy club and Lo and behold,
it went fucking great.
And I was on cloud nine until Lisa had to see.
Yeah,
she didn't even take me down.
I thought it was funny that that's the thing about groups he kisses.
Give me on,
once you join a group,
like you fucking,
you know,
be it rescue dogs,
uh,
environmentalist group or a fucking the religious right.
You just,
you just spin off into,
I don't know where you go.
And it's because you're hanging around people who are all saying the exact same
shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like a bunch of chicks sitting around
who are like 12 years old just in a bedroom covered with Jonas brother posters,
you know,
how the fuck do you think they're going to,
they're going to dig in to find anything better than then and they're not.
And you're,
you're the the adult version.
And then I think even fucking makes sense.
That's just fucking insane.
I mean,
I love dogs.
And not being able to fighting is,
I'm probably going adopt one,
probably gonna rescue one.
You know,
why not?
Because I'm fucking give a shit.
I don't give a shit,
but you know what I mean,
like I want to do it because it's a lot cheaper.
You go down to here and I a fucking pet store,
they want to like two grand for a bulldog.
You know,
when I go down there and I'll get one that's been locked up a little bit,
it's got shanked a couple of times.
You know,
it's got to get,
you've got the cobweb tattoos on the back of his fucking hind legs,
you know,
with that elbow is for a dog.
Um,
anyway,
she,
let's,
uh,
let's plow ahead here with the podcast.
So anyways,
this is a,
this is the podcast.
Like I said,
if you knew them,
you knew one of my page.
We actually have a new section this week is,
I actually started,
you know,
I got some time off here coming up,
so I wanted to go check out some movies.
And,
uh,
you know,
people tend to amp things up about movies.
Um,
like a,
you know,
like,
like the reviewers.
So I just wanted to hear from regular people cause you know,
people amped up that tropic thunder.
Like it was the funniest fucking movie since animal house.
And I went to go see it and it was definitely funny,
but you know,
it wasn't,
you know,
I don't know.
I hate when people do that.
All right,
so here we go.
Here's some movie reviews I asked about,
I was thinking about obviously seeing the Dinero Pachino thing,
a righteous kill and I'm somebody who goes by bad dog said,
um,
I had to see this movie because of the narrow Pachino wearing it.
Exactly.
That's why everyone's going to see it.
She said,
I thought it might be close,
be a close second to the departed.
Well this movie was so bad.
How bad was it that if it weren't for Dinero in Pachino I think it would've gone
straight to video.
It was like a really,
really bad made for TV movie.
All right.
Now that's kind of what I've read on the Internet.
But this other person sent me an email about the same movie and said,
I think the movie righteous kill was good.
Obviously p Pachino into narrow made it great.
But even without them,
I think the plot was really cool.
Now granted that kid had a picture where he was holding up what looked to be
some sort of dildo between his legs.
So that kind of knocked down his credibility.
But what if he's just being wacky?
See this is what sucks.
This is what might suck about this.
These movie reviews is uh,
you know,
like those sayings,
how you got all those things in life.
But did you can always have another saying that it like,
you know,
penny saved is a penny earned.
Then you got,
you got to spend money to make money.
You know,
walk softly,
carry to carry a big stick.
The greasy wheel,
the squeaky wheel gets the grease.
So what we see will,
you know what I'm saying?
So now I don't,
I don't know.
I'm going to go a bad dog on that one.
So basically,
you know what?
I think this section just give people a heads up.
If you saw a good movie and,
or if he got completely fucked over on a movie and you want to,
you want to do a year little rant.
I will read about how awful the movie was.
Um,
somebody else suggested burn after reading was outstanding.
Dark humor shows how ass backwards,
backwards and retarded our government agencies can be.
Malcovich is brilliant and it Brad Pitt.
Is it perfect.
Chad?
All in all great movie and I'm fairly picky about mainstream movies.
All right.
All right,
so I'm going to check on,
is that the Coen brothers movie?
I'm definitely going to check that one out.
Um,
brought ted,
it looks fucking hilarious in it.
Oh,
that's right.
John McAfee punches him in the face.
I'm going to see that.
Um,
anyways,
let's get to the podcast questions.
I know this is a little disjointed this week.
Um,
I kind of had a little difficulty trying to remember which ones I answered in
which ones I didn't because I did two podcasts that were never heard.
And uh,
someday when I die they will rerelease them.
Like when a miles Davis died and they started,
you know,
I like when they do that to people,
they,
they released a CD of him fucking playing the trumpet when he was taking a shit
in his bathroom.
Um,
you know,
basically stuff that they never wanted released.
All right.
Podcast question one a bill.
Will the cubs win the world series?
Why or why not?
Uh,
I hope they do.
I'm pulling for the cubs and if not the cubs,
I'd like to see the devil race.
Uh,
just because,
you know,
they're both great stories.
One team that just sucked forever for a Goddamn hasn't suck forever,
but you know,
you know what I'm saying?
I don't even get enough stupid cubs curse.
I'd like to see that.
But um,
you know what,
I think the angels are going to win it because he ain't that they're built to
win it.
They got all the pitching,
you know,
killer one to starting rotation and they got dice clay.
They got a great fucking bull pen they added to share out.
I mean,
come on on paper,
they should fucking do it.
Who knows?
And I would say that they are the angels because they always used to choke in
the playoffs,
but they did one in 2002 so I've got to give it to them.
Um,
oh,
and also speaking of sports,
I got to man up here and bring up my fucking patriots is a bunch of douchebags
in New Jersey and Florida rocking back and forth in their cubicle right now.
Totally excited.
All right,
I'm going to take my lumps now.
The New England patriots,
I last,
well actually I didn't even get the globe two weeks ago.
As everybody said,
the sky is falling because Tom Brady got knocked out and completely ignored the
fact that the rest of the team also,
when 18 won 18 games in a row before getting bitch slapped by the fucking
giants.
And I said that they'd beat the jets because they had fucking George Blanda
under center.
All right.
And what did they do?
They went out and they beat the fucking jets.
So I'm,
I'm sitting there,
I'm on a roll and write all these ESPN guys are fucking jumping ship.
And I stood there and said that they were going to fucking win.
I on in there like George Clooney and perfect storm going down with the boat
right
now.
What happens then?
I'm like all the dolphin.
You fucking kidding me.
It's a dolphin.
It's motherfuckers went one and 15 last year.
Joe Reporters running his mouth again like he always does.
He's like,
he's like the new Brian Cox,
you know,
ended up to her.
How did you know?
So I'm thinking it's a lock,
but what I did,
I forgot about Chad Pennington.
I forgot that he was their quarterback and I've always liked that guy.
He's a fucking winner,
but he's got bird bones.
You bump into him and he fucking need be breaks his femur.
So even then,
I still would affect the fucking pats.
I would've thought they'd go 23 and 17 when I figured that they'd win that.
But Dude,
Jesus Christ,
that was some of the worst defense I've ever seen.
That one fucking play with that guy.
He breaks through the lines,
I should say,
goes untouched.
And then that one Patriot dove into them with his shoulder and he just sort of
bumped them.
You know,
like when they score touchdowns,
they jump up and they bump into each other.
That's how hard he hit him.
The douchebag bag announced it goes,
oh,
he breaks a tackle.
No,
he didn't
fucking,
it was a pathetic display by defense.
And,
uh,
I actually think it's going to be a good thing for the Patriots because that's
the first time I've seen Belicheck behind the podium talking about shit that we
have to work on and he's being serious.
Okay.
And the dolphins totally celebrated.
They dumped the water,
like they just won the fucking super bowl,
you know?
So,
uh,
I think it's going to work good for them.
So next week,
what?
Next week they got to buy.
I don't give a fuck with their plane the week after that,
I think they're gonna they're gonna win that one.
Oh,
you fucking motherfuckers.
You know what?
As you guys,
you all,
you just hate the Patriots.
You hate us and US three fucking ranks.
You hate Belicheck because he ran off the field before the end of the Super
Bowl,
which I actually really fucking,
that was really bad.
But you know,
whatever.
He gets caught with a camera and all of a sudden you're going to question all
his fucking super bowls and they make up that shit that they were watching the
rams,
which turned out to be total bullshit.
All you motherfuckers,
you know,
so you know what?
This is all,
I'll take comfort in the jets.
Then I went in at the sheer,
okay,
where are you right now in East Rutherford listening to this.
You guys ain't win shit.
The dolphins,
you know when shit either.
If you win five games this year,
you're going to be fucking excited.
Okay?
It fucking stadium has been as empty during dolphins games as it has been from
Marlins games.
All right?
This is what you get when you guys fuck with me.
I've got a ton of emails.
Everybody giving me shit.
Um,
whatever.
I can't complain about shit.
Okay.
One of the world's series of fucking NBA title three Superbowls and another
world series.
You know what I mean?
Do you know what I mean?
Fucking championship hats.
I have,
I'm rubbing it in right now cause this is all I can go with cause we got our ass
kicked by the dolphins so I'm just going to be an arrogant fuck here.
You know what I mean?
I still even got my fucking Shit Celtics Championship tee shirt.
I haven't got that.
And you know your giants fans the second you want it.
You all ran out there and grab it the next fucking day didn't ya?
I'm still waiting because my closet is overflowed with fucking championship
shit.
All right then what have I talked a little bit of Shit.
Reality is,
is uh,
I actually,
I can't say I'm nervous about our season.
I mean it kind of ended when Tom Brady fucking went down.
But uh,
I still think,
I don't know all the bill look tough.
Bill's look tough.
Even then fucked the bills.
They're not going to win.
Who's going to win it this year?
I only think the cowboys,
Tony Romo,
he's a bit of a flake.
He still,
he still,
he still fucking fumbles the ball in his own end zone and rather than fallen on
it,
he fucking kicks it over to the other team.
That guy,
I don't know about him,
he still stuck and is Terry Bradshaw.
Terry shows the first couple of years he was looked upon as a bumbling idiot and
I,
and he's still fucking there.
So anyways,
yeah.
What the fuck am I talking about?
I got to wrap this podcast up.
This is all of a sudden,
this is just turned into one of these,
uh,
these fucking sports shows.
Did I ever make fun of this shit you don't like,
worst thing I hate about sports shows is when they have that fake half a
football field and all those old ex players go over there.
Can I talk about that last week and it didn't get published.
Do you remember this line watching,
you know,
Terry Bradshaw bent over and a three point stance and watching the top of his
head turn red as they,
as they try to fucking show me what a screen pass looks like.
It's like I know what it looks like.
Can you guys and your old rickety knees get back behind the fucking studio?
I don't want to know how hard it is for Tom Jackson to fucking the lineup.
I liked that guy.
I don't want to see how old he is and the effects of knee surgery in 1978.
Did he ever have it?
Was that Randy granted,
shy?
I can't fucking remember.
All right.
And with that,
uh,
I think that's going to be it.
I think it was going to get for the podcast this week.
Please subscribe to it.
Um,
did I do overrated?
Underrated.
I don't think I did that either.
It's something you don't want.
It is,
I'm looking at this fucking thing and it's a mess in front of me.
It really is a mess.
I can't tell what I've read and what I haven't read,
so I'm going to have to clear all of this shit out.
So if I didn't read your overrated,
underrated,
please send that shit in again.
I swear to God,
I will read it next week.
And um,
I think,
uh,
I think that's it.
I know I gotta,
I got a TV show coming out on jet is spot on.
Jim Norton's a down and dirty with Jim Norton on Hbo Coming Up.
I did some stand up and I had to go on off this comedian Sean rouse.
Please check him out.
He's one of the funniest dudes I've seen in a long time.
And uh,
and with that,
the last thing I want to talk about is I once the last game in Yankee Stadium
and as a red sox fan,
I gotta tell you,
man,
that was really a,
it was sad and confusing.
I still don't understand why the fuck
they're leaving there.
I didn't go to a game,
this ship,
but I went last year.
It's,
I mean,
yeah,
it's old,
but you know,
fix it up a little bit.
All your Mojo is in that fucking park.
Why are you going across the street?
I don't know who said sad and it made me feel old and uh,
I had this weird thing where I wanted the Yankees to lose.
So the red sox would clinch a playoff spot,
but I didn't want the Yankees to lose.
I didn't want them to lose the last fucking game.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't take hatred of the Yankees to that fucking level or I'm going to be a
comment on that night,
you know?
I don't know.
I don't know why they did that.
And I got to admit,
I saw the new Yankee Stadium and I think it sucks.
I think it sucks.
You know what it looks like.
It looks like fucking,
uh,
the new tiger stadium where the old tiger stadium used to be right on top of the
game.
They,
they,
they get shit to spread out.
I also thought they were going to do the overhang,
like the old Yankee Stadium and have the facade up there.
They have it,
but it's not hanging over the upper deck.
That's what the fuck I wanted to see.
I wanted to see like,
you know,
when guys came up to bat be looking out in right field,
and Mickey Mantle hit that thing.
That's what I wanted to see.
And they didn't do it.
They just,
they got a fucking,
they got,
they got a couple of nods to the way the thing used to look,
I'm telling you can be one big fucking Sushi,
one big fucking Sushi bar.
Uh,
it's going to stick.
I don't like it.
I'm going to tell you right now,
I loved going to Yankee Stadium.
I love going there.
They had fucking,
you know,
you sit up top,
you sit out in the bleachers.
Those are like the real fans and I swear to God,
those fuckers,
they're not going to be there.
They're going to try to go there.
They're going to charge him $9 million for a brand new fucking stadium that
didn't even need it.
Um,
I hope I'm wrong.
I hope I'm wrong because I noticed last night when I was watching Yankee stadium
just has the heads of that great fucking sound when the crowd's going nuts.
That used to just drive me nuts when the red sox would fucking lose to them
every year.
But like,
I just hope the acoustics and the,
they're fucking with it.
It's like Barbara Streisand getting a nose job.
And all of a sudden she never did it because she didn't want to fuck with this
sound,
this fucking with their entire history doing that shit and like,
you know what happened to the upper deck collapse?
You know what I mean?
They're fucking getting rid of it.
Like the way people get rid of laptops rather than getting some more memory in
it.
Well fuck it.
I'll drop another three grand.
Except you guys are paying for the laptop.
You're getting fucked.
The Ami pot holes is going to be in New York City because of Yankee state new
Yankee Stadium and the mets got a new stadium and the giants that getting a new
fucking stadium or the jets can a new stadium.
That's sad sack fucking franchise.
They played in the baseball field and then they fucking moved into giant
stadium.
What a fucking loser franchise.
They really aren't.
You know what your problem is?
Is you got to,
you know,
what is your main fan?
Is Somebody dressed like a firefighter?
Okay.
And I know he's a real firefighter,
but when that guy puts them on his shoulders,
I mean Jesus Christ.
Why don't they just fucking do a fucking,
why don't you just join the Goddamn village people?
That's what they look like.
They look like a cover band for the village.
I'll read a fire man and you being a blue collar worker and you just put me on
my shoulder.
You know,
I just realized that way through that is Angus gets on Brian Johnson's
shoulders.
I forgot about that.
Speaking of which,
ACDC has a,
uh,
a new world tour coming up and I am calling every favor in that I fucking know.
All right.
I want to sit right next to Phil Rudd's drums.
That's what I want to sit.
You know,
I got to go see him and his three places to see him neither seem,
and Madison Square Garden,
you see him at the La Forum or you go and you fucking see him and Oakland
Coliseum and uh,
AC DC fans know why that's a big one.
That's what was one of their first big shows.
They opened up.
Van Halen was on the bill.
I just read this great book about ACDC cause uh,
those are the only kind of books I can finish.
You know what I mean?
I got this book about Churchill and Gandhi.
I mean,
I'm up to page 30.
I started reading it.
Uh,
I think when Clinton was in office,
helps me go to sleep.
I like read half a page or like a nurturing and,
and Obama and I just fucking pass out.
Um,
I just literally lost my train of thought.
Oh,
what the fuck is
term memory?